time for our seen and unseen segment
where we expose what's really going on
behind the big cultural stories of the
day in tonight's segment Roseann may be
getting a little less political in his
rebooted Murphy Brown about to take on
us at FoxNews for answers we turn to New
York Times bestselling author the wheel
Wilder series Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo all right Raymond
Roseanne what is it what's going well
the ABC head of entertainment this week
said Roseanne's gonna back away from
politics it's gonna focus on the family
this season but today
Roseanne tweeted out ABC has been
nothing but supportive of me the presses
misrepresented what the ABC president
said it looks like she's going to keep
on this train where there's a balance
between politics and family let's face
it it is the story of this family that
keeps America yeah what about the
politics are only if she wants to keep
ratings you got to have some politic
politics because it's funny
yep and it's real meanwhile there's
Murphy Brown oh no Murphy Brown we
asleep okay let's watch you couldn't
tell the evening news from an episode of
Entertainment Tonight the problem was I
didn't know what to do with myself and
then we had an election a whole hog
politics that was Betty White she is a
little she's moved into where the
tapioca said at this what she's uh I'm
getting there too she looks great but I
didn't even know that was the voice it's
very husky she's going to be a host like
morning Jill opposite her son who's on a
Fox and Friends types I said morning
okay okay voices then there's a long
career for me at Fox you know the CBS
the CBS entertainment chief said we
probably won't get Roseanne style
ratings I think he's wrecked all right
now I know you're not a big fan of
reboots I'm not but there's one that is
really working and it's on a streaming
service my 15 year old Lorenzo started
watching this I said what are you
watching it's on YouTube red and it's
this are you
a bunch of teenagers that didn't beat up
any teenagers I kicked the crap out of a
bunch of who deserved it
thinks he can bring Cobra Kai back to
the valley not on my watch this is the
Karate Kid reboot but it's working 51
million people are watching this
it's the biggest streaming show in all
of television it is doubling Handmaid's
Tale stranger things huge audiences now
why is this working Lord the 80s are
making a big comeback it's nostalgia for
people our age okay all the kids in this
the 80s
rocked okay all the hair bands come on
you got a great hair bands you got great
great economy got Reagan for 8 years it
was awesome so look it was young wax on
wax off they are killing the competition
this thing has just been renewed for a
second season my favorite part of Karate
Kid was sweep the legs Johnny no no
sweep the name at the legs you don't
know anything and then the best one was
when he's first learning karate and he
looks down he looks down at the ground
about heels I stun your son is that what
you do with the Ingram truth yes every
night okay when they don't look at me
well I'm waiting for Golden Girls cheers
and magnum p.i comes long as they don't
ask me to star and go the girls they
want Tom Wolfe we both knew him I knew
him what a man what a man one of the
greatest writers National Book Award
winner
listen let's watch the intellectuals in
in New York they were startled by that
because I was I had been writing about a
lot of groovy things they thought I must
be like them and when it came to
politics when I went into a room full of
journalists or writers in general people
would looked at me at me as if I just
raised my hand and said by the way I
forgot to tell you I'm a child molester
well he was incisive the words right
stuff liberabit limousine liberals
good-old-boy all those terms came from
Tom Wolfe a great novelist and a social
observer like one of the best interview
I ever did on radio was Tom with Tom
until until I was on the show now
exactly are you getting ready for the
Royal Wedding yes
I'm preparing - you ready yeah I don't
care who takes her down the aisle and at
84 million dollars to the British
taxpayers that's a lot of time for a
widow not any proof not at Westminster
Abbey yes we're just looking at the
dresses all right